le président de la république
monsieur le président de la république
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez recueilli 18
millions six cent soixante dix huit
mille six cent trente neuf voix c'est à
dire
la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés dès lors le conseil
constitionnel vous a proclamé élu
président de la république française
monsieur le président de la république
nous vous reconnaissons comme grand
maître de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur
je fais le serment de léguer une planète
plus vivable et une france plus vivante
et plus forte vive la république et vive
la france
[Musique]